Singapore, the island nation...
...which has emerged as a shopping and entertainment haven,...
...is located 137 kilometers north of equator...
...and at the southern tip of the Malay Peninsula.
It lies in the north of Indonesia and south of Malaysia.
There are very few city - states remaining in the world...
...and Singapore is one of them.
Also, it is the smallest country in the whole of Southeast Asia,...
...with an area of 704 square kilometers.
With consistent growth and development,...
...facilitated by pragmatic economic measures,...
...fueled by foreign direct investment,...
...the standard of living of the people in Singapore...
...has increased a lot since its independence.
Singapore is the 17th wealthiest country of the world...
...in terms of per capita GDP.
Singapore's population is around 4.68 million.
Though Chinese forms the majority of the population,...
...the country's official language is English.